[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna paradies schönen guten abend und
willkommen den sport hat norbert lehmann
für sie ein stück von mir schauen wir
auf die wichtigsten themen heute
alarmierende zahlen das rk ii meldet so
viele neue infektionen wie noch nie die
gesundheitsminister ringen um einwohner
kurs für den winter
gegen das vergessen vor zehn jahren
endete die nsu mord serie bei der zehn
menschen umgebracht wurden viele fragen
sind noch immer offen und
klima kassensturz die pandemie hatte den
weltweiten co2 ausstoß kurzzeitig
gesenkt nun droht ein neuer emissions-
rekord
[Musik]
höchststand bei den krone infektionen
was tun darüber beraten seit heute die
gesundheitsministerin und minister von
bund und ländern in lindau am bodensee
es wird bereits eine verlängerung der
korona notlage gefordert die der
bundesgesundheitsminister ja ende
november auslaufen lassen wollte blicken
wir auf die zahlen binnen 24 stunden
wurden 33
1949 neuinfektionen registriert
5912 mehr als vor einer woche die sieben
tage instanz ist auf
154,5 gestiegen und auch das lässt
aufhorchen die zahl der todesfälle in
deutschland ist im vergangenen jahr um
4,9 prozent gestiegen sagt das
statistische bundesamt auch wegen corona
bei vier von 100 verstorbenen ist cupid
19 die todesursache gewesen vom treffen
der gesundheitsministerin und minister
alexander pohl der bayerische
gesundheitsminister klaus holetschek
spontanbesuch in einem bus vor dem
tagungshotel in lindau die 74 jährige
christel show aus freiburg lässt sich
hier ihre auffrischungsimpfung geben ein
glücksfall wie sie sagt die 16
länderminister und der
bundesgesundheitsminister sind sich
einig booster impfungen sind ein
entscheidender weg aus der pandemie ich
glaube man hat sich schon verständigen
können dass es wichtig ist diese
auffrischungsimpfungen schon in einer
größeren art und weise durchzuführen
gewissen aus den daten von israel dass
wir mit diesen der impfung
möglicherweise auch die chance haben
diese welle noch mal deutlich zurück zu
bringen zur eindämmung der korona
pandemie ist aus sicht der
gesundheitsminister außerdem ein
verbindlicher rechtsrahmen notwendig ein
rechtsrahmen wie ihn die feststellung
der epidemischen lage geschaffen hat
diese notlage nicht zu verlängern aus
sicht der bundesländer ein fehler wir
sind mitten in einer epidemischen
notlage noch drin das will ich an dieser
stelle auch noch mal erklären wir
brauchen als länder ganz klar eine
bundeseinheitliche gesetzliche grundlage
dass wir bestimmte schutzmaßnahmen auch
durchsetzen können
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn hat
er sich noch ende oktober für die
beendigung der epidemischen notlage
ausgesprochen er zeigt sich
gesprächsbereit so muss der deutsche
bundestag entscheiden die rechtliche
grundlage ist entscheidend das habe ich
immer gesagt einigkeit unter den
gesundheitsministern herrscht weiterhin
zum thema impfpflicht die soll es etwa
in pflegeheimen nicht geben
es ist also doch wieder eine
verlängerung der chor ohne notlage im
gespräch stefan leifert beobachtet das
treffen in den lauf für uns davon müssen
wir uns auf härtere maßnahmen einstellen
ja das dürfte wohl die bleibende
botschaft dieses treffens der
gesundheitsminister hier in lindau seien
angesichts der rekord instanzen
angesichts der immer dramatischer
werdenden lage auf den intensivstationen
stimmt die politik die bevölkerung mal
wieder auf einen harten winter ein aber
bei aller ähnlichkeit der situation
heute mit der vor einem jahr gibt es
doch einen entscheidenden unterschied
und das ist der dass die politik dieses
jahr die situation heute vor allem als
eine pandemie der ungeimpften definiert
und das hat konsequenzen auch für die
maßnahmen die maßnahmen die jetzt hier
ersonnen werden das sind vor allem
welche die dann die gruppe der
ungeimpften zielgerichtet treffen soll
vielleicht kann man es auf die formel
bringen er flächendeckende zweig
konzepte als flächendeckende lockdown
auf welcher gesetzlichen grundlage das
ganze dann stehen soll das ist nach wie
vor eine offene und sehr kontrovers
diskutierte frage darum geht es jetzt
auch heute abend hier beim treffen der
gesundheitsminister viele halten es für
einen schweren fehler die epidemische
notlage ende november schon auslaufen zu
lassen denn sie würde es den ländern
leichter machen maßnahmen zu ergreifen
das dürfte jetzt eine der ersten großen
fragen werden für die entstehende ampel
koalition in berlin gelang stefan
leifert
die auffrischungsimpfung soll einer der
wege seien die vierte welle zu brechen
schauen wir uns das genau an in
deutschland haben bisher fast 2,4
millionen menschen diese booster impfung
bekommen vorne liegt berlin wo schon 4,9
prozent der vollständig geimpften dem
booster gekriegt haben schlusslicht bei
den auffrischungsimpfungen zurzeit
sachsen mit einer quote von 1,7 prozent
niedersachsen liegt dazwischen mit 25
prozent wie das mit dem impfen dort
läuft berichtet fabian köhler aus
hildesheim
es ist die dritte corona impfung die
agnes knoppik direkt in ihrem zimmer des
christophorus stift in hildesheim
bekommt für die 85 jährige ist es
selbstverständlich sich erneut impfen zu
lassen
zwei tage lang sind die heim
mitarbeiterinnen gemeinsam mit den
mobilen impften einer hausärztlichen
praxis im pflegeheim unterwegs rund 150
impfungen wolf julia pop und carola
spiele verabreichen an die bewohner und
das personal
hier im hildesheimer pflegeheim ist die
hilfsbereitschaft sehr hoch fast alle
bewohner sind geimpft und gut 85 prozent
der mitarbeiter natürlich wäre mehr
immer besser das wissen wir natürlich
auch tun wir auch fast dafür wie
überzeugen und reden und versuchen das
eben in die gänge zu bringen sind aber
damit auch schnitt der gesellschaft aber
eigentlich besser als die gesellschaft
eine impfpflicht für medizinische berufe
sieht man hier ein heim skeptisch die
befürchtung ist dass das den
personalmangel in der pflege weiter
verschärfen könnte so setzten die
beteiligten hier auf aufklärung und
freiwilligkeit
um die korona politik geht es heute auch
bei maybrit illner wieder winter wieder
kein plan heißt die frage um 22 uhr 15
im zdf
spd chefin saskia esken will auch
künftig parteivorsitzende bleiben
mehreren medien sagte sie ihr ziel sei
es den eingeschlagenen weg fortzusetzen
sie haben sich entschieden ihre
bewerbung für das höchste parteiamt zu
erneuern co parteichef norbert walter
borjans hatte seinen rückzug angekündigt
im gespräch für seine nachfolge ist
generalsekretär klingbeil
heute vor genau zehn jahren endete in
einem brennenden wohnwagen in eisenach
eine rechtsterroristische mord serie
deren hintergründe noch immer nicht
vollständig aufgeklärt sind das neonazi
kern trio das sich selbst
nationalsozialistischer untergrund
nannte ermordete zwischen 2000 und 2007
zehn menschen fast alle von ihnen hatten
eine zuwanderungsgeschichte jahre lang
ermittelten die behörden in die falsche
richtung auf dem rechten auge als sei
man zu lange blind gewesen so
bundesinnenminister seehofer güter
neufeld berichtet
stilles gedenken heute in zwickau dem
letzten wohnort des nsu trios erinnerung
an die opfer des terrors
eisenach vierter november 2011 auf der
flucht vor der polizei setzten die nsu
terroristen böhnert und mundlos ihr
wohnmobil in brand und erschießen sich
vor gericht kamen beate geb die
gefährtin der mörder und vier gehilfen
des trios anwälte der hinterbliebenen
meinen es muss weitere helfer gegeben
haben die heute noch frei herumlaufen es
ist ein ganz großes anliegen vieler
überlebender und auch hinterbliebener
der terrortaten des nsu dass dieses
netzwerk aufgeklärt wird dass diejenigen
gefunden werden und zur verantwortung
gezogen werden die tatorte ausspioniert
haben die die opfer ausgesucht haben die
möglicherweise waffen beliefert haben
dass das trio so lange unentdeckt morden
konnte bis zehn menschen gestorben waren
es lag auch an der schlechten
zusammenarbeit der behörden die lehre
daraus eine datenbank beim
verfassungsschutz wo polizei und
geheimdienste ihre erkenntnisse
austauschen dabei geht der blick vor
allem ins internet
wir mussten erleben dass insbesondere
die attentäter von von halle und von
hanau sich im netz radikalisiert haben
in speziellen bereichen des netzes
teilweise auf spiele plattformen in
chatforen usw wir müssen einen radar
anwenden um solche
radikalisierungstendenzen sehr früh
erkennen zu können dafür bräuchte man
hoch bezahlte experten für
informationstechnik doch die sind mit
polizei gehältern schwer zu gewinnen
lückenlose aufklärung der taten hatte
die kanzlerin versprochen bei mir im
studio ist unser terrorismus experte
felix zimmermann felix noch immer sind
drängende fragen offen welche
gefühle drängende fragen auch nach 13
untersuchungsausschüssen und einem sehr
langen fünfjährigen strafprozess einsatz
was den nsu angeht woher hatte die
gruppe so viele waffen wie hat sie ihre
opfer ausgewählt und natürlich gab es
weitere mittäter und gehilfen die
bundesanwaltschaft ermittelt auch immer
noch gegen neun unterstützer hat aber
nicht genug beweise für eine anklage
andererseits natürlich fragen was die
behörden angeht was wussten v-männer
warum war ein mitarbeiter des
verfassungsschutzes vor ort oder im café
als einen der morde passierte und warum
wurden akten geschreddert die antworten
liefern könnten also insgesamt kann von
einer schöpfen und aufklärung nicht die
rede sein sie haben die
ermittlungsbehörden gerade schon
angesprochen haben die die gefahr von
rechts denn jetzt besser auf dem schirm
das kann man schon sagen man muss ja
sehen als diese die rechtsextremistische
terror serie begann haben die ermittler
das überhaupt nicht auf dem schirm
hätten das gar nicht für möglich
rechtsextremistischen terror sondern
haben stattdessen bei den
hinterbliebenen nach den tätern gesucht
und der nsu hat sich ja dann selbst
enttarnt inzwischen wurden aber lehren
gezogen viel mehr personal für die
beobachtung von rechts
verfassungsschutzpräsidenten mussten
gehen das sind also schon konsequenzen
allerdings muss man auch sagen
verheerende anschläge von einzelpersonen
konnten eben nicht verhindert werden und
das ist eben der grund dafür dass die
behörden unisono davon ausgehen dass die
größte gefahr für die demokratie und
sicherheit in deutschland vom
rechtsextremismus aus gilt vielen dank
für diese wichtigen einschätzung felix
zimmermann
im kampf gegen die klimakrise ist das
wichtigste ziel viel weniger
treibhausgase in die atmosphäre zu
entlassen die realität aber ist eine
andere wie eine studie berechnet danach
wird in diesem jahr weltweit fast
genauso viel schädliches kohlendioxid
ausgestoßen wie im vorjahr die
einsparungen im pandemie jahr 2020 nur
eine kleine delle vor allem china und
indien produzieren immer mehr
treibhausgase von der klimakonferenz in
glasgow volker anders
die wiederauferstehung der
weltwirtschaft lang ersehnt nach dem
pandemie lockdown hunderte milliarden
wirtschaftshilfen sind geflossen schnell
die wirtschaft wieder in gang bringen
hieß das ziel und das mit den
vorhandenen mitteln auf basis fossiler
energieträger klimaschutz nebensächlich
heute in glasgow das wissenschaftsteam
des global carbon project zeigt die
folgen auf die co2 emissionen sind
wieder so hoch wie vor der krise
das heißt wenn wir den ausstoß bis 2050
auf null bringen wollen dann müssen wir
ihn um etwa die menge reduzieren wie
2020 in der korona krise und zwar jedes
jahr
beispiel südafrika 90 prozent kohle
strom im netz nur ein prozent
erneuerbare energie und ein marodes
stromnetz ungeeignet für die
energiewende nicht
nur expertenwissen ist für die
energiezukunft gefragt zusammen mit
weiteren ländern baut deutschland
aktuell eine strategische partnerschaft
mit südafrika auf
wir versuchen die tradition von einem
kohleland in ein land mit zero emissions
zu unterstützen wir gehen damit einmal
mit geld voran natürlich mit 700
millionen euro aber auch mit unserer
erfahrung in deutschland denn wir
versuchen ja genau gerade das auch in
deutschland kohleausstieg in südafrika
auch mit hilfe privater investoren rund
8,2 milliarden dollar beträgt das
gesamte investitionsvolumen
für die klimakonferenz hat das projekt
modellcharakter ist auch für andere
kohle länder interessant globaler
klimaschutz notwendig ist deutlich mehr
internationale zusammenarbeit
für herausragende journalistische
tätigkeiten werden einmal im jahr
fernsehschaffende mit dem hanns joachim
friedrichs preis ausgezeichnet heute
abend die preisverleihung auch in unsere
kollegin katrin eigendorf für so
wirklich ihren mut ihr können und ihre
authentische empathie für die opfer
eines historischen versagens gemeint
sind die menschen in afghanistan nach
der machtübernahme der taliban besonders
die kinder sind in not wie der aktuelle
beitrag von katrin eigendorf zeigt
wenn fatima und ihr bruder morgens das
haus verlassen dann führt ihr weg nicht
zur schule sondern raus auf die straße
sie müssen geld verdienen
es ist eiskalt fatima ist krank sie ist
gerade mal acht jahre alt und schon für
das überleben ihrer familie
verantwortlich
ich bin hier um zu arbeiten weil mein
vater mich gebeten hat rauszugehen und
geld zu besorgen und essen nach hause zu
bringen
bereits im september habe ich in kabul
erlebt wie sich kinder verzweifelt an
die scheibe unseres autos drängten nun
steht der winter bevor eine millionen
afghanischer kinder drohen nach
einschätzung von unicef an hunger zu
sterben sollte nicht schnell dringende
nothilfe das land erreichen
fatima hat glück gehabt sie hat an
diesem tag genug verdient um brot zu
kaufen
brot ein bisschen tee mit zucker davon
ernähren sich immer mehr familien ob
fatimas brüder hungrig ins bett gehen
hängt von ihr ab
ich verdiene 100 oder 200 afghani am tag
und bringe essen mit nach hause wenn ich
nicht arbeite und essen mitbringen wenn
sie hungrig bleiben eine große
verantwortung für ein kleines mädchen
vor einigen monaten ist fatima noch zur
schule gegangen doch das ist jetzt
vorbei und wer weiß ob sich das noch
einmal ändert in diesen tagen haben sie
wenig hoffnung
zurück nach deutschland
es ist eine tat die fassungslos macht
eine mutter aus solingen bringt fünf
ihrer sechs kinder um das war vor einem
jahr heute hat das landgericht wuppertal
die 28-jährige zu lebenslanger haft
verurteilt wegen der besonderen schwere
der schuld ist eine entlassung nach 15
jahren nahezu ausgeschlossen das motiv
der tat die verurteilte habe wohl die
trennung von ihrem damaligen ehemann
nicht verkraftet so das gericht
freunde treffen oder sport im verein für
kinder und jugendliche war dass während
des lok downs lange nicht möglich und so
haben sie sich die zeit anders vertreten
am handy oder am pc die folge die
mediensucht es stark gestiegen
220.000 jungen und mädchen nutzen
computerspieler inzwischen krankhaft das
sind 52 prozent märz 2009 10 vor corona
das zeigt eine studie der krankenkasse
dak darin wird von einer sucht
gesprochen wenn kinder und jugendliche
mindestens vier stunden täglich mit
zocken verbringen
und wir kommen jetzt der
fußball-champions-league arbeiten
gestern abend gibt's ja nicht so gut für
die band ja allerdings leipzig kann das
achtelfinale knicken und dortmund total
geknickt weil eine umstrittene rote
karte für abwehrchef mats hummels mit
der 1 3 heimniederlage gegen amsterdam
beitrug der bvb kann aber trotzdem noch
in die ko runde kommen
mats hummels nach spielende mit
diskussionsbedarf sein platzverweis für
dieses foul in der 29 minute fragwürdig
trotz video assistent bleibt es bei rot
umso bemerkenswerter dortmunds
nachdrückliche spielweise foul an
bellingham den strafstoß verwandelte
marco reus in der 37 minute 1 zu 0 in
unterzahl und ohne den verletzten
holland hält dortmund den vorsprung bis
zur 72 minute dann der ausgleich durch
tadic den führungstreffer für ajax
erzielte in der nachspielzeit trifft
noch klasen entstammt 1 zu 3 eine
bittere niederlage für dortmund
ja und auch leipzig gefrustet trotz
starker leistung daheim gegen paris st
germain die führung durch nun kongo
schon in der achten minute dann aber
kassierte leipzig zwei gegentreffer
durch mein album das 1 2 in der 40
minute und kurz vor abpfiff schaffte
dann sowas ley noch den ausgleich aber
zu wenig keine chance mehr für rb aus
achtelfinale
[Applaus]
fußballclubs müssen auch in zukunft
damit rechnen wegen krawallmachern unter
ihren fans vom dfb eine geldbuße
aufgebrummt zu bekommen der
bundesgerichtshof bestätigte heute die
rechtmäßigkeit von solchen vereins
strafen
dominik koepfer bärenstarke auftritt
beim atp turnier in paris endete heute
im achtelfinale er verlor gegen den
polen hubert rogatsch mit 1 2 sätzen und
freiwasser olympiasieger florian
wellbrock der hat erstmals einen
internationalen titel auf der kurzbahn
geholt bei der em im russischen kasan
gewann er gold über 1500 meter freistil
florian wellbrock ist und bleibt der
beste deutsche schwimmer zu beginn
bewegen sich der italiener gregorio
paltrow
weltrekordhalter über diese strecke auf
der kurzbahn und der deutsche fast im
gleichklang die beiden bestimmen das
rennen doch wellbrock baut seine führung
nach und nach aus und bleibt elf
sekunden unter dem alten deutschen
rekord 14,09 8 altran er wird zweiter
erfreulich der dritte platz für den
wunsch dorfer sven schwarz
etwas vom sport danken und jetzt wird es
noch winterlich denn in einigen regionen
ist ordentlich schnee gefallen wie hier
auf dem fichtelberg im erzgebirge sorgte
er bei den einen für freude bei anderen
für chaos zu erheblichen behinderungen
kam es auf der völlig verschneiten
brennerautobahn in österreich die
wichtige nord süd achse richtung italien
wurde zeitweise gesperrt
und wie lange sich der schnee bei uns
hält und ob da noch mehr kommt erfahren
sie gleich von katja honnefer claus
kleber begrüßt sie um 21 45 zum heute
journal
[Musik]
guten abend tief peter ist ein schnelles
tiefs zog heute von den ostalpen über
österreich und tschechien weiter bis
nach polen und hat inzwischen bereits
die ostsee küste erreicht es brachte
schnee mit in den alpen aber auch in den
höchsten gipfellagen der mittelgebirge
hier bei uns in deutschland vor allen
dingen brachte das tief aber regen mit
und der breitete sich hier von bayern
über thüringen und sachsen weiter aus
bis nach sachsen anhalt berlin und
brandenburg und sogar bis nach
mecklenburg vorpommern und in
mecklenburg vorpommern wird es heute
auch noch am längsten in der nacht
weiter regnen sonst lassen die
regenfälle allmählich schon nach im
westen kann es auch mal auflockern dann
bildet sich rasch nebel denn die
temperaturen zum beispiel an der ruhe
sinken auf drei oder vier grad noch
kälter wird am alpenrand mit minus 1 bis
minus fünf grad unter dem kältesten über
schnee an den alpen sonst liegen die
temperaturen bei 7 bis 4 grad und morgen
liegen die höchsttemperaturen zwischen 6
grad hier im oberpfälzer wald oder auch
an den alpen und 12 grad in ostfriesland
und die regenwolken der nacht werden
morgen ein bisschen zurückgedrängt dann
regnet es noch am längsten im thüringer
wald und im erzgebirge sonst wird es
ganz freundlich und auch das wochenende
verspricht uns häufig sonnenschein im
norden dagegen auch regenschauer guten
abend